- [Narrator] Judging by the grandness
and length of this wall,
you could be forgiven
for thinking that it's in China,
but this is the Great Wall of India.
(upbeat music)
The Kumbhalgarh Wall is
located in Rajasthan,
roughly a 10-hour drive from New Delhi.
Its remoteness has caused
this stunning location
to be relatively unknown, even to locals.
The wall is made of
thousands of stone bricks
with artistic flourishes on top.
It has seven gateways and took
over a century to construct.
It was a place of refuge
in times of danger.
The wall snakes through
valleys and along mountaintops.
After the Great Wall of China,
it is the second longest
continuous wall in the world.
It is 22 miles in length and surrounds
the fort of over 300 ancient temples that
were believed to have been
built in the fifteenth century.
In 2013 it was declared a
UNESCO World Heritage Site.
A majority of the wall sits high,
serving as a lookout and
giving incredible views
of the surrounding
mountains and farmlands,
unlike anywhere else in India.
(upbeat music)